- She's special.
She really is, man.
She's like gonna win.
Let me help.
Like, you're gonna win.
Like, for real, like honestly.
You know what's running
through my mind right now?
Straight up?
I'm like, I am so happy
I have that on film,
'cause one day, you're
gonna be the biggest star
in the world and I'm just
gonna keep putting out the clip
where you're like, "Wow, he's the best."
(laughing)
- [Tierra] Hi, I'm
really glad to meet you.
- Hi. I am so excited right now.
- [Tierra] Yes.
- My man, I'm Johnny.
- This is Johnny, manager.
- Johnny, how are you?
- Kineet, manager.
- Kineet, how are you?
- Hi.
- Tatiana, make-up artist.
- Hi, Tatiana.
- We're all fans, I'm sorry.
And then Nick, my photographer.
- Nick, how are you?
No worries, I'm super flattered.
Get in here.
I'm so excited for this meeting.
- Yup, me too.
Can I sit right here?
- Yeah, sit, sit, sit anywhere.
There's plenty of seats for everybody.
I'm glad you came up.
Were you coming up anyway today, or?
- Yeah, I have like a press run tomorrow.
All the blogs have been
posted, mumbo jumbo,
just like, we wanna meet so yeah.
- You are going to be a
ridiculously big star.
It's super weird.
Like, you know what's crazy for me?
This is now happening
to me mainly in hip hop.
Like that Uber email you
see over there, right?
These stocks, Twitter, Tumblr,
like what I wrote about
in my first book about like social media.
It's so crazy, I didn't know that I--
I feel like now I have one
core talent which is like
I can see it and like it
used to be about like trends,
or like companies and now
I've been really focused
for about a year hard on like hip hop.
And like, it's really interesting.
Honestly, Mike really helps
me but not everything,
like there's a lot of things
that I see that I'll be wrong.
Or like I won't fuck with
something that becomes enormous.
But some stuff is just black
and white obvious to me.
Man, I really think you're--
I'm really excited for you.
- That makes me feel really good.
- And what's interesting is I haven't--
I've lived like nobody being on Twitter.
Like I was on YouTube when nobody was--
like there was not one video
that had a million views
on YouTube when I started.
Like, and so I've watched people
like never saying the word
social media or YouTube or Twitter.
So that's been cool, right?
And I did it with wine
which is way less cool,
like with like New Zealand
wine and South African wine,
but I'd never done it with people.
And now I'm doing it with people.
So now I'm like, "Man,
what would it be like
"if I was doing this six years ago
"and like The Weeknd
was just sitting here?"
(laughing)
Right?
I'm like, "That's gonna be
a weird feeling, right?"
Anyway, nonetheless, I am
so intrigued by your talent.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you, I can't.
- I was so pumped when you hit me back
and were like, "We're
fans", I was like, "Yes!"
(laughing)
- [Nick] We were pretty excited.
- We were so surprised when you told us.
I was like, "Oh my God,
I can't believe this."
Like we just, we was looking
at each other like shocked.
Like, "What the fuck? Oh my gosh."
- It's so crazy, right?
Like I know it's happening,
like I don't get ahead of myself,
but I'm like wow, if you
would have ever told me--
I mean, you have to understand, I'm 42.
Like, if you would've
told me 13, 15 months ago
18 months ago, that my
co-sign would mean anything
in any shape or form...
(group laughing)
...it's just so funny for me.
It's like an out of
body experience, really.
So what's going on? What's going on?
- Really, I'm just working
on this new project.
I don't know, I've been
working on it for a while.
Just like me in general,
like I'm just kinda like,
I'm just like, I'm scatterbrained.
Like I have like, I think of ideas
like every second of the
day and like these two
like they help me really
to just kinda like
just balance it and you
know just like give me
like some type of direction and of course,
just organizing like
the things in my head.
So like it was our idea to just like
put together like, well to
try to put the way I feel
into music of course,
'cause that's what I do.
- Tell me more about yourself.
Where were you born?
- Myself? I was born in Philadelphia.
- What part?
- North. North Philly.
Yeah, so this kinda like,
they're trying to make it good now.
They had like-- Temple
has taken over everything.
- I know, I know.
- The things that I
saw when I was younger,
it's not there anymore.
It's just like a nice ass
building now, so but yeah so.
- It was not as nice of a
building when you were growing up.
- Yeah, yeah, like so, yeah
so it changed and whatever.
But single parent, my mom,
just she took care of me.
- You have siblings?
- Yes, I have a younger
brother and younger sister.
We're all five years apart,
so I'm kinda like setting like the tone,
like I'm doing good and they
have to follow right along.
You know what I mean?
I'm setting the standard, so yeah.
- And when did you know
you were music-ed out?
- Well, really, like I
kinda always just loved.
Like at first I wanted to
be a dancer then I was like,
I was singing a little bit
then my aunt got me in church,
so I was like, "Okay, I really like this."
But then I got in school,
I forgot what grade it was,
but we got introduced to
poetry and it was like we had
to get up in front of the class.
This was like the first time
we had to get up and present
and all of my friends, we
were so-- I was nervous
you know it was like, "Oh
my God, we gotta like--".
And it was just, I think it
was called freestyle poem
or like spoken word or
something like that.
That was like the specific
thing that we had to do.
And she was like, you know,
"You just get up here and
just express yourself."
It has to be a page long or
whatever and everybody did it.
I was the last to go
up, 'cause my last name
was always on the roster
'cause it's Whack.
- I got V.
- Yeah, V, yeah, so you
understand what I mean.
- I know how it is.
- Yeah, you understand what I mean.
- This is literally my exact story.
In sixth grade, I had to
give a speech in class.
And I went last so I had
to fuckin' be nervous
the whole time and I wasn't
the public speaker I am today,
'cause I had to like talk
about shit I didn't care about.
- Right, yeah.
- It wasn't as cool as what you did.
I had to like, you know, like nonetheless.
So I know. Keep going.
- Yeah, so, like I went last
or whatever and like the poems
were so like, I didn't
really like poetry at first.
I liked the fact like my mom had me--
Like I had The Cat in the Hat, Dr. Seuss,
One Fish, Two Fish, Red Fish, you know.
But like I just like certain poems,
they just don't make any sense to me.
But I just love the fact of just like
that you can rhyme any word that you--
Of course it has to rhyme but
we just put words together.
I just love that.
I'm so fascinated by that.
- [Gary] Right from the beginning?
- Yeah, from the beginning.
- [Gary] So you did your thing.
And it went over really well?
Like right out the gate?
- Like the kids in class were just like,
"Yo, you gotta like turn it into rap.
"Do rap, do rap, do rap."
And I'm just like, "What?"
I just you know, but I like the attention,
because for awhile I
just went through a thing
where I was getting teased and everything,
like just, I never got any attention.
- [Gary] It was the
first time you got love.
- Yeah so I was like, "Oh,
this is what they like?"
And then I was like, "Mom, get ready."
Yeah so I got two composition
books and by month two,
I just had like every day I was
coming to school with lunch,
and I was controlling everything
like everybody get ready,
get their lunch, sit at the table,
and I'm just spitting these raps.
Just like poems, but they
were turning into raps
and it just went crazy and
you know like neighborhood--
- [Gary] How long ago was that?
- That was like, it was like,
- [Gary] Were you in high school?
- No, no, no, middle
school, middle school.
Yeah, middle school so--
- [Gary] Okay, nonetheless,
now I got the picture.
So, and then what happened?
- So then after that, I just kinda like--
the composition books
really just helped me,
'cause I had to make my mom
go out and get the books.
She's like what do you
want these books for?
You already have school books.
And I'm like, "No, I want to write poems."
And then she started seeing
how thick they were getting
and how I kept going
back to the Dollar Store
to get new books and she was like,
"Oh okay, you're on to something."
So then I had an uncle, you know he--
I guess she told him or something like,
"Yeah, she's been doing
poetry or whatever."
'Cause you know you meet your family,
and they're like "Well,
what are you doing?"
and she's like, "Oh, she writes."
And so then he was like, "Oh
you should try it over a beat.
"And you gotta talk about stuff that--
"you know, like the streets."
So I went up and I looked at like the most
gangsterest rappers and I
started talking about stuff like
fucking pilling your
scout back and shooting,
stabbing your mom and like
you know but I feel like it--
I still say some of that stuff
but I feel like the way--
'cause that's literally what
my mind think, you know.
But like you know, I was just,
I went through that phase
of just trying to figure
out like I want to be cool
to like the hood 'cause that's
where I was in the hood.
You know, like that's
what I want to talk about.
But really I wanted to
talk about dinosaurs.
Yeah, right yeah.
But then it's like so I went
through that whole thing
with just trynna like you know--
- Conform?
- Yes! Yes.
And it was so difficult but
I just had to accept it.
I was like, people would
literally call me weird
and I hated it.
- Yeah but you know what?
You got so lucky because
if you were coming up
on a different era, that
would've been the only option.
This is the best time
to be in hip-hop ever,
'cause it's a mature state
like you know what's funny?
I've seen the exchange
between you and Yotti
and I always use him as an
example of this exact point,
which is that if Yotti
came out like that when
I was growing up, he
would've got his ass kicked.
(laughing)
I always say that it's
crazy to me that like
Ice Cube and Urkel had sex
and made the new age rapper.
Right like if you would've
told me that's what would've
happened 20 years ago, I
would've never believed it.
But it's so amazing that you
can be your authentic self.
A female with your angle on
things and it's like hot.
Uh, it's why I wish people
understood hip-hop better.
It's gone from really not accepting,
like in a lot of ways in my opinion,
to unbelievably accepting
in its current form.
- [Mike] One thing you said recently,
so the next part of her story is--
I don't know how long you were in Atlanta,
but at some point, she was like
"I'm not just rapping to
rap, I want to be an artist."
- Yeah, so that happened.
That was like, so middle school happened.
It was just poetry, poetry.
And then I went to high
school and then I started
this random thing, like
just going into high school
like my first year, 9th grade.
Me and my mom were just driving,
we were going to visit my grandma,
my grandma's in heaven now, rest in peace.
We were driving down like
North Philly same thing
and she was like, "Look."
and then I looked up
'cause I'm kinda like,
my chair was always back.
I didn't wanna like be out.
I had homework, projects,
I was stressed out.
It was just like 9th grade year.
I'm just like, "What the fuck?"
- The first year of high school sucks.
- Yeah, so what happened?
Oh so I looked to my right
and I see a big group of guys
just on the corner just random
and I see like a nice camera.
Like that looks like
a beautiful like yeah.
No but it looked Canon, you know yeah.
So I'm like, "Okay, this
kinda looks like official."
You know but I'm still
kinda like in my mood.
Like I don't, you know--
'cause my chair was
literally back like this.
And then she was like, "You
should get out and rap."
I'm like, "What? I can't just do that.
"Like what do you mean?"
And she's like, "No, get out and rap."
So she knows me so she can
tell that I'm thinking.
And I'm just like--
And she's like, "Alright,
I wanna circle the block."
So she circles the block and
I'm thinking of all the raps
I have in my head and then I get out.
I was like, "Aye yo, can I rap for y'all?"
(laughing)
They was like, "Yeah."
And then I was just like, "Hi."
They like, "What's your name?"
"Well they call me T-Dizzle."
'Cause they just called me
T-Dizzle and it was like
just neighborhood stuff
like whatever so that's just
the first thing in my
head that I thought of.
So they're like, "Alright,
go ahead shorty."
So I'm like, "Hey, yo."
And then I just was rapping and they like,
they were looking like, "I'm
not really feeling this."
And then this one guy, he's
not here, rest in peace.
He just put his arm
around me, he was like,
"No, like she's hot.
Like y'all gotta listen."
So I guess he ran that whole block.
So once they like--
'Cause they were kinda like
backing away a little bit like,
"She kinda weird, she's
talking about dukies
"and booties and just weird, whatever."
Yeah and he saw it and
once he put, he literally--
You can see the video.
You can still find the video on YouTube,
- Oh yeah?
Yeah, he put his arm around me.
- Oh that's cool.
Yeah, I wanna see that bad now.
Actually pull it, go get it.
(laughing)
- No, not while I'm still here.
Yeah, oh you were on Hot Ones?
Did you go?
- I did and dominated by the way.
- Oh wow, I love spicy food.
- Go watch it.
I completely annihilated that show.
- Okay, yeah we gotta watch it.
Okay so he's like, "I'm
rocking, I'm rocking with her."
And then that's when I found out like,
'cause I got the information from the dude
who was holding the camera
and he had done like a popular
like blog and you know
he had a good webpage,
it's called "We Run The Streets",
that's what it's called.
So like the rappers like Meek
Mill coming up, Three Dollars,
like all the battle
rappers were coming up,
you know on his platform or whatever
so I was like, "Oh my
God, I can't believe it."
It was just so good and then he's like,
"Yeah shorty, I wanna put it up tonight.
Receive the feedback."
And then it was like one night 6,000 views
then like a week it was like 12,000,
it just kept jumping like so
good and then he was like,
"Yo, you didn't have any buzz
and like this is going crazy."
And of course it was like,
"15-year-old jumps out
"and blesses the camera
with her mom in the car",
or something like that, like
that was the whole thing.
So after that, Meek tweeted
me, like Cosmic Dirty,
all the big people, all
the big heads from Philly
just like were tweeting
me and I'm just like,
"Yo, this is not happening."
Like I just couldn't believe it.
- And then everybody in school was like--
that must've been crazy.
- Yeah but see the
thing was like you know,
that was just so random, you know,
me just not even wanting
to be outside and you know,
be in that car like,
and then it just was--
And then in school, I was a problem.
My principal, she hated
me, I know she did.
I just controlled everything
like whatever I said,
like it just went like you
know like just whatever.
- You had too much juice?
- Yeah, I did, no literally I did.
And so then like you
know, I just was going
on the radio shows
freestyling, freestyling.
But I just got tired of
that like I was going
into the stuio sessions and
just rapping over a beat
that you know, weren't
original just like killing it.
But I mean of course, I'm
just trying to get a buzz
so I'm doing what I got to--
- You're honing your craft,
you're getting exposure,
you're going through the process.
- Exactly so but it just like--
I told you I have a
short-ass attention span,
so it just got boring really
fast, you know what I mean?
So I just was like, I wasn't feeling it,
like people were calling
like they were signing
and all this stuff and whatever.
Meek was trying to figure
something out and I'm just like,
"Eh, I'm not really feeling it."
I had been in sessions and everything
but I'm just like, "I don't know.
"I don't wanna just freestyle
like my whole life."
You know what I mean?
'Cause every time I would
try to even just dibble,
you know into like something
original, everyone's like,
"No, just kill some beats, just
kill some old school beats."
And I'm like, "That's cool but I don't--"
Like I just started to get stressed out.
And you know the only person that really
understood me was like my mom.
Like I was telling my
friends, they're like,
"What do you mean?
"You have the hottest people calling you
"and just do what they want you to do."
Once somebody said that
to me, I was just like,
"Nah, I can't do this."
So me going through that,
and then this was like 11th grade year.
Yeah this was like all
happening 9th, 10th, 11th,
when like everything was
like happening for me.
And so my mom was like,
"You know, I'm thinking about moving.
"I want something new or whatever."
And I was like, "I need something new."
And that's when we moved to Georgia.
- You moved to Georgia
for your senior year?
- For my senior year, yeah.
I finished my last year of high school.
So I stayed there with her for
about two and a half years,
like almost three years and I just kinda,
I deleted social media,
this is when I was going
by a different name, T-Dizzle,
Dizzle-Dizz, whatever.
And deleted social media, I
just was trying to find myself.
You know what I mean, like I'm
just trying to figure it out.
And what happened?
Well when I went, this is
funny 'cause when I went down
to Georgia, people already
knew who I was in school
like so that's how I knew
that it was like serious.
Of course I'm in Philly and
like everybody knows who I am.
But when I went to Georgia and seen like,
"Oh that's the girl, I think."
Every time I'm walking in a hallway,
"That's the girl. That's the girl."
And I'm just like, "Oh my God."
I thought I was gonna get away from it,
but I'm still in it and so but eventually,
I got my first job, it was a car wash.
I worked in a car wash, Mister Hot Shine.
And I was making so much money.
So like tips were fucking crazy.
I didn't even care about
my check like just like,
my tips were so crazy
and I was the only girl,
like everybody else was like
they had just got out of jail,
I was working with all guys, killer like--
fucking everybody was crazy
there but I was the only girl
and I was just getting tips so good.
I loved that job but my
goal was I wanted to save up
for my first laptop and a mic,
that's what I wanted to do.
So yeah, I worked that job,
got my laptop and a mic.
I just start recording myself
and I was finding little beats
and everything 'cause I could
use my buzz a little bit
to like you know, reach out to
certain people like you know,
we producing this stuff and
yeah, we just started like
start doing some original
stuff and like I just kept it
to myself on that laptop
and then when I felt like
I was starting to get
it, 'cause I was like,
"I gotta change my name.
"I wanna use my real name, Tierra Whack."
Like I was making a master plan,
just trying to reinvent myself.
- Being patient?
- Yes, but it was so much like pressure
because everybody in my
corner was telling me
like they didn't want me to do what I did.
They didn't want me to take that break.
- That's when you know it's right.
- Yeah, you know and so yeah.
And so like a year and a
half, almost two years.
'Cause yeah it went by
whatever and I was still just
recording on the laptop and I
started to just feel confident
but I didn't show anybody any of my music,
so that's kinda crazy to just you know,
like I had to just keep
this like to myself.
- You were the case of the other version.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You didn't have the impatience
that everybody else had.
You were already in a
place where everybody
heard everything you were
doing so it was easier for you
in a lot of ways to keep it to yourself
'cause you knew what the alternative was.
You've gotten the digital exposure,
you got radio station exposure.
So okay, so keep going.
- So that's when I
called this guy, Kineet.
So when I was T-Dizzle,
(laughing) I used to hop around
studio sessions all over
Philly, just trying to just find
that right engineer you
know, until it feels right.
This guy is really, he's like really hard
to like get connects
with, he's like a caveman.
You have to really be
like good or like just
something special about
you so that's why I know
that I'm special like he reminds me.
Like I called, I got in touch with him
because I remember I had so many sessions,
I had this one session and
it was of course with him
and I got one really
good original song done.
Out of all the fucking sessions I did,
it was so fucking many, I always
did freestyles, freestlyes.
I went in the studio
with him and he was like,
"Yo, you could do original if you want."
I was like, "What?"
Like that was like the first
engineer that said anything
like that in Philly for
me and I'm just like,
"So you don't mind if I like, you know,
I could work on original stuff?"
He's like, "Yeah, you can
do whatever you want to do."
So I always remembered that and I said--
Keep in mind I was still
in Georgia thinking this,
like the whole plan right.
So I connected with him on Instagram like,
"Yo, I got some new stuff.
"I really need you know
an ear or whatever."
And like I said, I kept in mind.
I'm sorry, I'm like backtracking,
trying to make sure I'm saying everything.
- [Gary] You're not losing
me at all, just so you know.
(laughing)
New York has become slow for me.
This shit feels in slow
motion, just so you know.
- That's good, that's good.
- [Gary] Know where you're sittin'.
This is slow motion, go ahead.
- So I always kept him in mind
but I knew he was hard to get
in contact with so I had to
make sure before I physically
moved back to Philly that I had
him on lock like I have him.
"You're the first person I
wanna see when I get to Philly."
So he hit me right back and
he's like, "Yo, where you been?"
Like what everybody's been asking.
"Where have you been?"
It's been two years
since I put anything out.
I was a leader and everything.
He's like, "Where have you been?
Yeah, come through man.
"You know we could work something out."
So I'm like, "Yes, this is all I need."
Like as an artist, if you have
an engineer in the studio,
you can do anything, you know what I mean?
So I got back with him, played my stuff
and I was so fucking happy.
- [Gary] You came up to Philly?
- Yeah, I came back to Philly.
I moved back to Philly with my grandma.
- [Gary] Oh, you moved back?
- Yeah I moved back, I was back so--
- [Gary] Your grandma who's passed?
- No, not that one.
This is Wilma Whack.
Wilma Whack is still
alive, she's fucking crazy.
- [Gary] Okay, so go
grandma Wilma Whack okay.
(laughing)
And you go play to him, you're nervous,
you're hoping it goes
well and what happens?
- He loves it, he loves it like--
- [Gary] And when was this?
- This was about three,
three or four years ago?
It was about three or
four years ago and she--
I like cued who she was at
that point 'cause I'm like,
I started calling her Dizzle
and she had changed her name
to Tierra Whack already so she
would check me immediately.
- [Gary] She's like, "I'm Whack."
- Yeah, don't call me that.
And I'd slip up 'cause I'm
so used to calling her Dizzle
but she don't, but she sent it to me
and she's like, "Whatchu think?"
I'm like, "This is crazy."
It was like way different from
what you were doing before.
And you know--
(laughing and overlapping chatter)
- [Gary] So he's blown
away and what happens next?
- And then I mean, I don't
wanna say it gets dry,
but it's just like we just
started working and he's like,
"Yeah, you can record
here whenever you want."
Like he literally like
moved his sessions over
and like just let me--
- So you created a project?
- Yes.
- And what happened? When did you drop it?
- No, no, no.
There still is no project
after all these years.
He just, like he's like,
"Yo, you can come in."
And he even showed me--
- He started teaching you?
- Yeah, he started
teaching me how to record
on a better pro tone and
logic and everything.
He was like, "Yo, I'll lock out a time.
You can just go ahead."
And he would literally
leave me in the studio,
just let me just clock out.
Yeah, 'cause that's what
I was doing on my laptop
so I guess he wanted to ease me into it,
which was the best plan
ever and then you know,
we just like, I've just
touched in so many genres,
because he just gave me
that like the playing field.
Yeah, the freedom.
- Do what you want.
- Yeah.
- That's what you do with
talent, you don't box 'em in.
- Yeah, it wasn't like,
"Nah, you gotta do this or make this.
It was like, "She's seen a lot."
- You're like, "You know."
- Yeah, like yeah.
- So and then like, I don't know.
That's really like the yeah.
- Yes, that's sort of the gist of it.
And then what happened was I know myself,
I don't like, I'm not that
good at being in the forefront
and I know that like
sometimes it can mess up
somebody else's situation
by not acknowledging
who it is that you are.
- Self-awareness is a leverage, baby.
- Right so I'm like, "She might
need, she want management."
I'm like, "Yeah, I could."
So I had him, who I've been
working with for awhile.
- I knew him too already.
- That's why I'm like,
"Johnny's good with business."
I'm not good with any--
of course, I'm tech-savvy.
But yeah, yeah so it
became all three of us.
- And when was that,
around that same time?
- Yeah, around the same exact time.
- And what's been happening
for the last three years then?
- Just everything.
So many people calling and just like--
- [Johnny] We've been being patient
for the last three years,
that's exactly what.
- Yeah, that's really what it is.
Like just like knowing the
right time to just like,
you know like drop here
and there and just like--
- When you have the talent,
you have the leverage,
your moment doesn't pass when you're good.
Like people are so confused.
- [Mike] When did everyone
start like Bibi Bourelly
who we really mess with
and liking her pictures?
You know what I mean, like
when did all this stuff?
- I don't know who that is, why?
- You don't know who that is?
She wrote, "Bitch Better
Have My Money" for Rihanna.
- Oh that's who, okay, it
sounded by I wasn't sure.
- And she liked your photo and Kei.
You know Kei, 21 Savage's manager?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She hit me up, yeah, yeah.
- Coach K likes everything she does.
(laughing and overlapping chatter)
But you know what I mean?
- As he should, Coach K's doing his thing.
- Everyone's watching you.
- Yeah.
- I think now is the time right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like what do you feel about--
- You know what's crazy
about "Now is the time."
Like for what?
So now is the time. Cool.
Like this is my whole
point, like this what--
I ever heard for the past
10 years of my life is
"Now is the time."
I wrote this, "Now is the time."
This now, "Now is the time."
You get the better question to your point
in the way you're looking
at it, that's right.
But I think the much more
interesting question is
"Do you at this moment have a sense
"of what you want to happen?"
And if you don't, then it's
just to continue to create."
Right, so like to me,
TV was always the time.
TV, I was like, everybody was like,
"Time is the time. This is the time."
And I didn't know what I
wanted and then when Apple
came along with a show where
it had three big celebrities
and then me, I knew that it
wasn't gonna be a big show
'cause I knew nobody
had Apple TV like that.
I just knew me positioned
with those three incredible
celebrities that were A-list for the group
that wouldn't know about it
'cause I knew I could make
people know about it, wasn't
even like about like you know,
I just wanted like just being
with Jessica, Will.I.Am,
and Gwyneth Paltrow for Hollywood,
put me on a different sphere.
It didn't matter what happened next.
That was the right time.
And so for me was a huge win even though
it didn't become Shark
Tank or American Idol.
It was a beat of beat, it was an industry.
It was the people that--
like I'm in a different
mindset for a lot of people,
on a different level for different people,
not that I need that
'cause I'd much rather have
three million followers on
Instagram than be on a TV show.
I needed it for the leverage
of other shit I may want to do.
- Right, okay, yeah.
- Got it?
So you're in it already when people
that matter are liking your content.
Here you come along, you discover it,
or we're looking at it
from a different way,
you know and you go and look.
Well then she's already
won that narrative.
Like when people go online
and see The Rock liked it,
they're like, "What?"
You know like right?
So for me, there's a
different thing which is
the different and right question for me is
"What do you want to happen next?"
- Can I tell you like the
process kind of or just like--?
- [Gary] You can tell
me anything you want.
- (laughing) No, you
didn't hear what I said.
Okay, I said I was
pregnant but I was playing.
- [Gary] I heard you.
(laughing)
If you were pregnant,
that's some real weird shit.
(laughing)
- Okay, so like it's funny
'cause we touched on this awhile ago.
I'm just kind of in a space
where like I don't give a fuck
like I just don't, like I just can't,
like I can't afford to care
because sometimes of course,
when you care, you overthink
and you think too much,
and it's just like something
driving you so crazy.
- [Gary] You know what's crazy?
You don't give a fuck and you don't care
because you've hit full maximum caring.
- Oh, that's perfect, that's perfect!
Yeah, that's exactly what
it is and it's just like,
I'm just kinda just whatever
comes to my table and like
to my plate, I'm just kinda
like, "Let's figure this out."
- [Gary] I'm listening
to you very carefully
and I've been really
listening to you carefully
in a different way and
now listening to you here.
I think the only thing you
need to decide is the--
so your stuff is so right, it's scary,
which is why all this is
happening, your stuff.
The only conversations the
three, four, five of you
should be having is, in the short-term,
"Where do we put that stuff?"
So when I hear what you're up
to like what you wanna do next
I'm like, "That's exactly right."
Because that's where you
want to put your stuff.
- Okay, okay.
- Got it? Like that's how I feel.
Everything I do is gonna be right.
I just have to decide
where I want to put it
and sometimes I wanna
put it in a paper cup
but sometimes I wanna put
it filling an entire room.
You're gonna always be right creatively,
you just need to think about
the context of the distribution
and what you want to happen.
- Right.
- I feel like also like Tierra,
one of the reasons why she
like doesn't give a fuck about
anything anymore and like what
you were just saying before
is 'cause like she doesn't
notice all these outside things.
Public victory is about accomplished.
She just had so much a
personal victory like she's had
so many like wins on the
inside and everything,
she's just like isn't ever
thinking about anything else
and now she just needs to get in--
- My man, I don't know
anything that anybody's doing.
(laughing)
People ask me shit all the--
I know what's going on
through other people's eyes.
I know what's going on in the streets
'cause I can see it through scale,
through his eyes and
through the feedback I get.
Like I spend time with you
guys 'cause I can almost
like weirdly like it's so
weird like I don't even
like talking about how I
learn, like I feel like
on some like weird superhero movie shit.
You guys come in here and I like take it.
Like it's so weird how I do it,
which just means I don't
know what anybody's doing.
I don't know about anything.
I know what it feels like to
be in your own little cocoon.
What I do think you need to do,
what I do think the
vulnerability to our system is,
is where you put it and why.
Like you can't get over-- so
couple things that are cliche
for people that are artists like you.
You need to be careful
to become too romantic
about your truth, let me explain.
What starts happening after
awhile is you manifest
into realizing how pure it
is and then the only thing
you care about is the
purity of the purity,
become a caricature of yourself.
Your biggest vulnerability
is you becoming a caricature
of your truth because you're
so right and what happens after
like after awhile is you're almost
subconsciously biased
becoming too artistic.
- Wow, we talked about that.
- [Kineet] That was crazy.
(laughing)
- We talked, that's crazy.
- So what you need to do is--
- It's like you're reading my palms.
(laughing)
- I'm serious, it's super
obvious to me right.
That's your only vulnerability.
Otherwise, you'll win.
Which leads me to why micro things matter.
This book matters to me
because it's a micro thing.
Like here's how it works for me.
This isn't about the money.
This is about a lot of
people learn from books,
like people could watch every video,
listen to every podcast, but
for some fucking reason--
Books, I guess it's all
gathered in one place,
I don't learn from reading
so I don't understand it
but other people really
learn from reading,
taking all the notes right.
Like the amount of people that
can take this book and circle
and highlight and put post-its
and that's how they learn.
And for me, I'm obsessed
with the legacy of changing
the game for people and so I'll
manifest this but is this--?
Does this represent me? Is this my--?
No, this is a micro thing.
And where it can get confusing,
especially at this young of an age,
is everything starts feeling macro
and you don't understand
what macro and micro is.
And all of a sudden, you
never put anything out.
And you become Dr. Dre in all those years,
promising albums coming.
You get too macro-ed out.
That's what happened here in that moment.
But he won and just by Dre
and he's an icon and there's--
because truth always wins.
If you're great, there's
nothing you can do to stop it.
(laughing)
But the key is you
start getting into that.
But you should put out a project.
And if it doesn't do well,
it's not gonna matter.
(laughing)
Like all the equity, you get
into a place where everything
that you've done that's been
so right for the last seven,
eight years, you think
that output determines
like it has a lot of pressure behind it
because you haven't done it,
like it gets overthought.
And it gets too precious and
then the timing's never right.
And it just becomes this thing.
And that's how special people lose.
Why do special people that
deserve to win bigger lose?
It's 'cause of everything I just described
for the last six minutes.
You gotta be comfortable
with micro and macro.
It's not selling out, it's not
putting it all on the line.
It's getting into that habit
of I do a lot of micro things,
like my sneaker, that was a micro thing.
I did a collaboration with
K-Swiss, I thought it was cool,
it was doing good, it
could've been a disaster.
And I think when you come
from the right place,
you can't fuck it up.
You have to think about that.
- That means a lot.
- I figured it would.
That's why I wanted to listen
way longer than normal,
because I felt there was a
whole lot in you and like,
I was right, you need
to embrace the micro.
'Cause you're so macro-ed out right,
that micro gets scary.
- Wow.
- There's so many things that so many
all-time greats did that were wrong
but nobody remembers what
The Beatles did wrong.
- That's true, very true.
- There's a lot of whack fucking
songs out of Jay-Z's now.
(laughing)
- I can't look at the camera.
- What people don't understand
is the wins outweigh
the losses and if you're
meant and you've got it
like that, it's like-- with who?
It's how it works, right?
When I say Lauryn Hill,
you're not thinking about the
900 things that are wrong,
you're thinking about the
fucking greatest album
that maybe ever was made.
- Yes, you're right.
- That's what you have
to figure out, got it?
- Yes, I appreciate you so much.
- And you know where it comes from?
And you'll love this,
it comes from humility.
I think what makes you
special is you have it.
I don't think-- I think it might--
I don't know, I'm going
on some good intuition.
I think you need to harness
it because when you harness
your humility, it is your
strength, but when you harness it,
it makes you realize
that the reason I'm right
is 'cause nobody gives
a fuck enough about you.
- That's crazy. This is crazy.
You're giving me chills, yeah it's crazy.
Wow, I got my pony for everything.
(laughing)
- It's right.
It's what it feels
like, it makes so much--
I can just see it, it's
as clear as day for me
what's going on with you.
Doesn't mean you need to sign,
but you should put out,
you know I always say
put out more stuff,
everybody's got their reasons
and versions but it's
always the right answer.
You just have too much in
you to like no put it out and
you're just putting too much
romance around the narrative
and you've been so good at
being the architect behind it,
but your pride sits within it.
- We need to hear this, like
we really needed to hear this.
(overlapped chattering)
Like you said everything.
This was crazy.
- It makes sense to me.
- Wow, I'm afraid of him, like I am.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, this is what I'm
good at, like it's really--
and by the way, this is what you'll have,
because this is the experiences
version of the talent I had.
I was sitting right there.
At 22, I was working at
my dad's liquor store,
getting shit on my all
my friends, parents,
and the whole world, like you
fucking suck so much that your
job outta college is you
working your dad's liquor store.
And I was like, "Keep talking."
You understand?
It was all here, I understood right.
I was patient, I did what I had to do.
But what I didn't have was 20
fucking years of experience.
You'll be talking just
like this in 20 years.
Experience matters, I now
understand 'cause I've tasted it,
'cause I had to go through
my own kind feeling
to be able to get it.
You know?
- This means so much.
I really appreciate it.
- Especially 'cause you
can help so many people.
Your music is so powerful, right.
Like all those stories and thoughts,
they need to see the world.
You're being selfish.
- You're right, you're right.
- I know.
- He's so right. Wow.
- So that's it.
You know, take this and
listen, let's be friends.
I really wanna be friends.
- I do too.
- Okay, good.
(laughing)
- I was gonna ask you,
can we buy a book today?
- You can get a book.
- No, I wanna buy it.
We can't buy a book?
- You can't buy it, but
I'm gonna give it you.
Alright, get me a pen, I'm counting.
- Mind if I take a few photos?
- That'd be amazing.
- No, the thing is like
the team wants a book.
Like we want to buy our books.
- You want multiple?
- [Kineet] Yeah, we wanna buy it though.
- I can't have you buy it.
That's just not gonna happen.
(laughing)
(pen scribbling)
- Yeah, go get me some.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Let's take a quick photo.
I gotta take a call.
I'll give you guys books.
You got it?
- Yup.
(camera clicking)
- For me, without the book
'cause I want it just me and you.
Get in here.
- [Nick] Alright, ready?
(camera clicking)
- Give me a hug.
- Thank you so much. Thank you.
- You're welcome, you're welcome.
She's special, she really is man.
She's like gonna win.
Let me help, like you're
gonna win like for real.
Honestly, you know what's running
through my mind right now?
Straight up?
I'm like, "I am so happy
I have that on film."
'Cause one day you're gonna be
the biggest star in the world
and I'm just gonna keep
putting out the clip
where you're like, "Wow he's the best."
Like just imagine on a very serious cake,
imagine you like film of
like you acting that way
but you were a 20-year-old Beyonce,
like that's what I think is gonna happen.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
That was incredible.
She was incred-- I really
liked that meeting.
(ringing)